hallo und herzlich Willkommen ich bin
Samy besser bekannt als her Tutorial auf
Youtube und ich brauche eure Hilfe
vielleicht kennen mich schon die ein
oder anderen und haben vielleicht fragen
an mich was ihr tun könnt ist mir so
viele Fragen wie möglich in den
Kommentaren zu stellen am besten wäre es
wenn ihr euch aufnehmt und eine
Videoantwort zu mir macht zu diesem
Video postet ja dann wird eure Frage
garantiert beantwortet also schreibt
Kommentare mit Fragen an mich und
hinterlst mir eine Videoantwort miter
Frage würde mich auf jeden sehrhr freuen
diese Fragen werden dann alle im
kommenden antworte Video beantwortet
also ich zähle auf euch und sag euch
dann schon mal tschüss bis zum nächsten
Mal